[Music]
so welcome to the very first ever very
first ever
tales with stormy it's a new feature
here on Sidetrack usually on side track
we're all yapping about you know TV
shows and movies and the latest
gossip coming out of Hollywood and
wherever else
we just don't talk about books here
we're going to talk about successful
cocktails what stormy is all about I
make a cocktail and I discuss a book
that maybe has not really made it to the
movie theaters or the TV screen
something that is really overlooked and
you should be reading it man so here we
go
so today's cocktail
is essentially it's just we're just
drinking Dipple pitch today right
we're gonna do about
four fingers of The dimple paint there's
really not mixing anything today it's
just we're keeping it simple since this
is the the very first we'll we'll do
just uh yeah that'll do it
nothing really too fancy
we'll add some Sprite
in just a y'all know this is sacrificed
many of you but you know I don't care
right so the the really cool thing about
this is
this definitely moved my storm base
so the really cool thing about this is
is like you really don't think this is
going to be a thing right so we have
the Hagen Hague dimple Pinch scotch
a friend of mine from work
turn me on to this idea actually his dad
turned him on to the idea
and for some reason it works now only go
out and get the regular Cheez-Its
don't get the smoked parmesan cheddar or
whatever other Tommy thing they're
selling
we just want the regular and if you want
to go extra big hey I'm all for extra
big that's cool so it's just like
take a cheesy
scotch
dude there's just something about
did Jesus
and the scotch
that really just makes it I don't know
what it is
let me try again just to make sure we
make sure we get the science through
this you just do
through observation and taste testing
uh-huh yeah
it's a miracle it's all I can say
it's a miracle
so today
there's one of the one of my favorite
sci-fi books and it's one I tend to buy
all my friends I must have bought it a
million times off Amazon
and that is
red Mars by Kim Stanley Roberts
red Mars
and it's part of the series you know
once you get into red Mars you're going
to go to Blue Mars and the green margin
I'll read the whole thing
but red Mars is essentially a book about
the
first explorer human explorers to Mars
those first that first trip
about the first hundred settlers
and at this point the books you know
there's already been you know um a human
landing on Mars but it was a return
Mission but this is the the first this
follows the story of the first hundred
settlers that's not coming back to Earth
at all and it's their and it's their
struggles both from a resource point of
view from a personality point of view
and especially from a political point of
view which was just the the politics of
it
was kind of refreshing at the very end
everyone came together and it was
and they're still Strife but a lot of
The Strife was well you'll find out I
don't want to give too many spoilers let
me take another cheesy hit
don't ask me why it's so good I don't
know
so
I would definitely add
red Mars I can't stand the Robinson to
your read list
and because as soon as you might as well
go get you know go on Amazon and get the
other two or your your favorite local
bookstore
and just get all three
red Mars blue Mars and green Mars green
Mars is just
out of this world awesome I mean
sometimes with trilogies you know the
first book is just fabulous and then
it's just not the second but it's okay
and then like you know it's so funny
this is the opposite this is very
very much of the way around the tension
builds the story evolves
and it really blooms into something that
is just really great just really great
and that's it here from the Sidetrack
cocktail laboratory so until next time
I'll be your bartender take care goodbye
[Music]